everyone could use a safe and thrilling
escape right now
and the number one michael jackson
tribute show in the world
is back and rocky is live at the strat
to show us how we can join
vegas's king of pop rocky
okay guys i'm sorry i'm having a hard
time not dancing and singing right now
we've got adapted vibes
on stage because we're at dress
rehearsal of mj live
which is coming back and reopening
officially tomorrow king of pop
aka the king of mj live that's the strat
how do you feel about that
welcome back everybody mj live at the
track we're gonna open tomorrow
we're so excited to be here you have no
idea how we doing i'm good i'm good i'm
so excited to talk to you about this
because when i walk in you're out there
singing so
what can people expect because you sound
like mj thank you oh you know we're
gonna expect
all the michael jackson his thriller
billy jeans smooth criminal
the entire jackson five madly human
nature you name it we're gonna be doing
all the michael jackson hits and i think
we also have some video to show you this
day obviously even his regular clothes
right now in his mask but you are in
full
costume impersonating nj full makeup
hair costumes everything mj live at the
strat tomorrow november 4th
come check us out yeah how do people get
tickets you can find tickets uh at the
box office at a strat you know
all over the place online you can go on
on the mj live website
tickets are on sale right now get your
tickets okay okay
i have to test you out i have to test
you okay i have a lyric for you
she's just the girl who complains that i
am the one
but the kid is not my son what song is
that guys i'll send it to you
thank you rocky mj no this is michael
jackson impressive
improv